my own view is that as a starting point
whatever the government proposes has to
be proved to be legal before it can go
any further as we've heard from the many
protests against these proposals the
detail of which we will not see until
tomorrow there are bound to be legal
challenges and I do not believe that
this is an issue on which the United
Kingdom government should break its link
with the European convention on human
rights that might happen as a result of
the proposals if they appear tomorrow in
a form that has been flagged up to us
also there are better ways of dealing
with many of these problems I would like
to see for example evidence that both
the National Crime agency and the police
were replying the resources which this
very important organized crime important
to the nation
is causing
um surely it should be right at the top
of the priorities of the police and the
National Crime agency apart from
possibly terrorism
and we need to see a change of approach
because simply saying we will deprive
people of their internationally
guaranteed right to apply for political
asylum in a country in which they arrive
is not going to be an adequate response
and it will struggle to find its way
through Parliament if the government
really proposes to take it through
Parliament I would have thought that
given the success that the Prime
Minister had with the discussions with
the president of France on the Northern
Ireland protocol talking about these
issues to the French finding joint ways
of dealing with the problem possibly the
establishment of holding centers on the
French side of the channel might be a
more fruitful way of dealing with these
matters let's just break down some of
the those three points that you've made
I mean obviously we are going to find
out more tomorrow aren't we about what
the logistics are and there are those
talks at the end of the week in terms of
the possibility of there being more on
the French side but but why why
shouldn't the UK break its links with
with human right international human
rights legislation do you think
because the European convention on human
rights is subscribed to by all the many
countries which are members of the
Council of Europe Which is far more
countries than the European Union and it
has been of great advantage in holding
some governments which have occasionally
strayed from the rule of law to account
given our great Democratic and legal
Traditions I would have thought that the
United Kingdom would not want to be seen
as an outlier in the human rights World
joining the likes of Iran for example
typically a country which is often cited
as the worst Exemplar of bad human
rights we do not want the reputation of
our country to be diminished under human
rights principles unless it's absolutely
necessary and I think that the
government will struggle to prove that
leaving the European convention would be
necessary
and in terms of the police and and the
National Crime agency are you suggesting
that they are not doing enough
well they haven't been very successful
the proof of the pudding is in the
eating
um the National Crime agency and the
police have considerable resources which
they do devote to the detection of
organized crime and normally to be fair
to them they're quite successful
for example the interdiction of
terrorist plots I used to be the
independent reviewer of terrorism
legislation so I can speak about this is
successful and has saved the lives of
many people I would like to see a
similar standard of effort put into the
organized crime of bringing people
across the channel in small boats
because I doubt if it's being fulfilled
at the moment as well as it could be